[Music]
cheers to national prosecco day i know
we got to fill these up in a minute but
we are celebrating with stk's executive
chef stephen hopcraft thank you for
joining us i'm so glad you're you're a
celebrity this is a big i tell myself
that every day what a celebrity i am i
know i know and you're not even i
believe me but go ahead come on i mean
look what you're making just alone that
is incredible i was telling him that you
know there's an art to making eggs
because
it's not easy and you can see i even
broke one of my yellows and that's no
yolk right there is that bad that's
pretty bad all right so we're talking
menu for brunch on the weekends and also
of course we're going to make that
champagne later
of course so right here what we have is
this is our truffle steak and eggs and
if you know stk the s stands for steven
the t stands for truffle and the k the k
stands for kick and booty so right here
i got a nice little
summer truffle that i'm just gonna grate
on there because you know a lot of
people like to shave them i like to
grate them because
it just makes it easier to eat
my mouth is watering right and then i
have what i like to call dirty sunny
side up eggs
you know you like a dirty hair in vegas
so what i did was i cooked the steak in
the pan and then i piled those eggs in
there it might look like a sloppy little
mess but in my opinion that's the way
you eat breakfast yes
the other thing i have going on right
here is a little lobster eggs benedict
we have a little tarragon hollandaise
some spinach of course some nice lobster
and uh an english muffin that is
delicious our producer just said those
are to die for they're to die for right
so uh what i'd love to show you is
please it is prosecco day it is and it's
prosecuted every day honestly if there's
any day that has an alcohol in it i like
to celebrate it just saying anyway
right just like the eggs i think so yeah
so what we're going to do here is i like
to put a little towel over the top
because all that pressure is gonna want
to make that champagne pop pop and
bottles
so the cool way to do it is not to make
a bunch of noise
and not to waste any champagne okay oh
wait let me let me do the honor sir
you've done enough okay i guess yeah
fair enough all right so we've got 40
seconds to pour a proper glass of
prosecco okay am i doing it right so far
i know you have to tilt the glass a
little bit right there you go just a
little see you got it and leave enough
room for the orange juice and then
that's yours and then this will be mine
come on okay
okay cool orange juice a little we're
making a proper mimosa correct yeah so
that's another thing that we have going
on with our brunch is bottomless mimosas
and you know we like to have fun over
there so
we want to make sure that you take
advantage of our bottomless mimosas and
of course we have
the uh bottomless buddy of mary's and i
can't tell you how excited i am to have
a drink with you cheers and celebrate
the friday the 13th because i think it's
a wonderful and you know i'm going to
come do this again at sdk i hope so
j.c i'll send it to you cheers